hello so I guess you have obviously seen
the topic you probably saw some
description which is why you're here
welcome thank you for coming I hope this
is an important topic for you or an
interesting topic anyway it's a mixture
between some patterns that I'm going to
show and also some code actually is
mostly based on my personal experience
but it is about micro services and
front-ends in this talk I briefly want
to give an introduction this comes in
two parts one a shorter part where I'm
explaining what this is all about where
it came from why the need and why am I
even talking about this and then in the
second part I'm going to show you five
different patterns for micro front-ends
what were they thinking what were people
thinking when they came up with this
idea this is probably very common to you
many of you have seen something like
this right this is a typical layout
architecture with what people often call
technology stacks you usually get
something and they are drawn at the
bottom with the databases you know the
drill right you get the DBA state away
administrators or all sorts of other
people dealing with some persistence
data storage messaging you oftentimes
have different teams that are
responsible for the back-end development
for the development on the server side
and you get front-end which today of
course splits in two major areas one is
the web that a lot of people of course
are having applications in and also
native mobile this split has been so
dominant for so long in the industry it
sometimes really hard to forget I've
even seen people talk about themselves
to identify themselves I've heard people
say I am a back-end developer as if they
are or I am a DBA what happened though
and you could have a whole talk about
micro services here what happened at
some point people realized while there
were some efficiencies to be gained by
having one team of DBA steal food all
the data bases the efficiency was not
there caulk on
turn anymore what they were most
interested in was cycle time they wants
to get out features very quickly it was
a competitor or is a competitive
advantage to get features out quickly
and this structure doesn't really help
your problem is if you want to get a
feature out you have that team
coordinate with that team coordinate
with that team and so on I've been
working with organizations who are
deploying into production several
hundred times per week it is set up like
that that is clearly completely
impossible so what did the industry do
basically their trend is on the side and
they said we want to do something like
this we want to have vertically oriented
functionality we want to build micro
services and we want to have
cross-functional teams that are
responsible for them these teams are
often in the Amazon language they talk
about to pizza teams they talk about
these big American pizzas and they're
saying the team should not be larger
than what you can feed with two pizzas 8
to 12 people cross-functional obviously
to clear up a misconception obviously
not everybody in the team needs to be
able to do everything but the team as a
whole should be able to do everything
from interacting with the user to their
persistent store and when you're set up
like this you gain the two benefits that
the original people the original
thinking behind microservices wanted to
have and that is on the one hand
independent evolvability the idea that I
can evolve the service independently I
can make changes without having to
coordinate with somebody else which
increases throughput and reduces cycle
time and the other one not so relevant
for us tonight was this idea of the last
rewrite that you can actually say I
don't really have to write rewrite ever
a big monolith I don't ever have to say
I want exactly the same thing but on a
different technology stack I don't know
whether you've been on projects like
that they're usually quite painful then
you could hear words like ugly words
like feature parity and all these things
and you're just doing a huge amount of
work just to go from one tech to another
microservices and a project that avoids
that because you can start you could
imagine these colors mean different
technologies you could start changing
your landscape but
as I said not the key thing for tonight
tonight I want to focus on the
independent evolvability because what
happened unfortunately is more like this
picture we've seen this quite a bit if
you think that gray line here is the
limit between the client and the server
the web browser at the top and the
server side at the bottom we saw lots of
teams writing very nice micro services
on the server side and then they had one
big application if you will one big
piece of JavaScript there was consuming
all those services there is often times
known as the front-end monolith there's
a huge problem with this kind of system
you're getting all the inefficiencies I
should say of micro services you have to
do all the work to now put a lot of
different services into production you
have to have lots of different build
pipelines you have to have complete
infrastructure automation you have to
find a really complicated solution for
monitoring to aggregate all the data
back you have all the effort you have to
do for micro services but you don't gain
any of the benefits because again you're
not getting the independent evolvability
because everything is in that big one
front end monolith some part of the blue
service is smeared across the orange
service is somewhere visible and each
time this team here that middle team
wants to release that service they again
have to coordinate because they're still
in the end working with the monolith so
this is worse than not having any micro
services having micro services on the
server and to monitor from the front end
is the worst of all worlds really
unfortunately that happened quite a bit
it was really unexpected and I know many
people who were there I mean I worked
with thought was in Europe many people
who were there at the original days when
we discussed micro services when James
Lewis worked at at the GES the
government digital service in the UK
where they started building systems like
that and it came unexpected because we
all had assumed that it was clear that
we meant something like this we really
meant that the services had the user
interface would interact that was
something that didn't occur to us but we
saw it happen quite a bit to the point
and know how many of you know this
thought was publishes a document called
the technology radar we
do this twice a year and at some point
in November 2016 when we were designing
or we were creating the technology way
that we said this is a major problem
2016 already the micro-services paper
came out early 2014 and rather than
saying don't do my don't do these
front-end monolith we thought okay we
should be more constructive we should
tell people maybe what else they could
do and then reluctantly we created a new
term front and sorry micro front end it
wasn't really necessary we thought
because we had micro services envisioned
to include the front end but everybody
or not everybody but many people didn't
do it so we said never mind the
development community has spoken micro
services to thing on the server side we
need something on the front end let's do
micro front ends and that's what we
stipulated in that edition the situation
changed even more as we notice that a
lot of the development effort that we
were seeing was shifting from the server
side to the client side what we saw is
misses was in volume 18 in whenever that
came out November 18 I think we said one
of the major themes of that raid I was
even that the browser's bulking up
there's more work in the browser I've
personally been on projects where over
70% of the code is running in the web
browser and only a small fraction is
running on the server and of course if
you then think back about the picture
then you have a handful of little micro
services truly micro mini services but
all everything else is really one big
monolith and you are exactly where we
were 10 years ago so that mean II can't
be it so we thought ok micro front-ends
what does it actually look like how
would you design or how would you build
micro front ends and over the years
given that we talked about this in
November 2016 we've done it before with
a thought works we're not a small
company anymore we've explored different
options in different contexts around the
world we started to realize that there
were certain patterns and these are the
patterns I want to present to you in a
certain order I'm going to show you the
most simple pattern first and then the
most complex pattern last that does not
mean
should progress from one to the other it
just means there's five different ones
there might be further variations I
doubt they're something completely
different if there is I'd love to hear
about it obviously and sometimes one
pattern is applicable sometimes you
might want to use a combination
depending on what you are actually
building the simple most pattern is the
web approach basically going from one
page to another page and all throughout
I'm using a hypothetical example of an
e-commerce site where you can buy shoes
a lot of it actually all of all the
examples I show you are actually rooted
in real examples sometimes I'll show you
a little bit of code that is changed to
protect the innocent
but I'm always putting it into that
context so what we are seeing here is we
have service number one that is
responsible for rendering what we call
the article detail page so there is a
page where the customer on e-commerce
web site can actually see details about
the product and they can make up their
mind whether that is the right product
they want to buy this will include a
longer description of the article
probably some high-resolution
photography maybe even like a 360 view
and so on like a lot of detail about the
article and then there's the second
service that is doing the order capture
it's the service that actually when you
click on the put it in the shopping
basket button that then gets activated
and does something else on the server
side to remember that you as a user
whose login actually wants to buy this
pair of shoes what is important to
remember is that the idea of
microservices was that they store their
own data so this service number one here
will keep most of the information I
talked about service number two will
have to know a little bit about the
products maybe the price for example and
it is totally normal in that case to
duplicate this information to have some
data feeds that are asynchronous that
are feeling service one with all the
detailed information and service two
probably only gets a small amount of
details I'm not really going to talk a
lot about the backend architecture
tonight actually I'm not going to talk
about it at all I just wanted to
highlight that it's ooh
that those services can act completely
independently as far as to user requests
go and if you then think oh my god data
duplication it's actually totally fine
and in many ways it's actually the right
thing to do for example if you're
putting a pair of shoes in the shopping
basket and the price changes you
generally don't want to user experience
where you have to tell the user the
price of the item in the basket has
changed I mean if you put something on a
wish list at say Amazon or so and you
keep it over there for a month that will
happen but normally actually these
services keep a copy anyway for a better
user experience but anyway
the most simple pattern is service one
rent as a complete HTML page this could
be a little little JavaScript
application that allows a bit more
interactivity and renders the whole
thing when the user then clicks on a
hyperlink to say add this pair of shoes
to my shopping basket it goes to a
different URL the URL at some point I'm
not showing this here is routed to a
different service and that service then
renders it back and shows the shopping
cart with say that new pair of shoes
added to it and maybe other things that
as a user I've placed in the shopping
cart beforehand if you can use that
approach it's the simplest approach one
of the reasons why the web works so well
is because you have that nice
abstractions you have URLs and pages and
your else can go anywhere this is really
easy to do unfortunately in many cases
is not sufficient because the users have
higher expectation for example they
might want to have something like this
and most ecommerce websites do this
actually you actually have a little bit
at the bottom at the top here where it
says you have so many items in your
shopping basket or even maybe showing
you the total price and so on again
assuming we have those two services how
would you deal with that if you do
server-side composition that means you
are rendering HTML on the server still
which is a common or invalid approach
especially if you have a lot of traffic
if you have a lot of customers and and
visitors on your web page it can make
sense you could do it like this you do
server-side composition so service
number one renders the HTML for the
entire page so when the URL comes in
there's a piece of software
that decides this URL should be rendered
by service number one because it is the
article detail page it went as HTML
which leaves conceptually a little gap
here and in the HTML code it puts
usually an include this is a directive I
would recommend to use edge side
includes it's a little bit more
standardized but many of the servers can
actually do also server side includes
ESI is just a standard and many of them
support it and this is actually correct
syntax so when service one renders the
HTML it includes this little bit here
and says at this spot please include
include navigation it should actually
say shopping cart here please include
that and then you have varnish or nginx
or something like that while they stream
the byte stream for the HTML page back
they pause briefly when they get across
one of the ESI directives they will then
resolve this make a request to service
to that returns HTML which they insert
into the stream when that is finished
they continue serving the data from
service one and the web browser sees one
HTML page of course you can easily see
how I can expand this and you can see
how when I copy paste this code together
I made a mistake you can of course you
said for navigation as well you can have
any heavy navigation here at the top or
for example if you think about an
e-commerce website again on the front
page you usually have multiple different
components coming from different
back-end services like recommendations
for you or like a shopping like what you
call it like a a set of images like
current offers and so on and so on and
you can do that very well when you do
server-side rendering with edge that
includes the key thing here is if you
think about it of course once this is
set up the teams can work independently
service two can completely change how
they render the shopping basket what
they want to display without ever having
to talk to service one the only coupling
you get is at some point service one
needs to include include the edge side
include they need to put that into your
code but I think that coupling is
totally fine because you only do it once
at the beginning and in a way you need
to do it anyway because this page needs
to somehow Express the intent that they
want to have the shopping cart right
but after that they can work on their
own I'm not going to go into complete
detail here but I want to show you this
as an example of one of the myths I've
heard this many many different times
that people say but but but if I use
server-side rendering and server-side
composition I can't use caching or
caching doesn't really work and all my
pages need to be cached and if I do
server side include then everything has
to have the same time to live and so on
so what if this is this here is actually
a little bit more from a debug version
this is the complete varnish
configuration to allow you to do a
different time to live so different
caches so you can see this at the top
there in the VCL fetch function you can
see some basic matching and it says if
the request URL is for a page then the
time to then actually do edge set
includes and the TTL you can see that
here the time to live is 30 seconds so
all those pages will be cached for 30
seconds that's usually quite a long time
if you talk about the high traffic
website if you get hundreds of requests
per second you are reducing the load on
the service in each one of the pages by
a factor of over 1,000 or PC don't think
about hours or so 30 seconds is actually
a long time when you need caching on a
high-traffic website but what you say is
and often times websites want to do that
they want to include some tracking so
they can track what where which web user
is going which of course doesn't work
when they get served cache pages so
we're saying here's if the request URL
contains the the past segment track I'm
saying actually no please don't cache
this ever and here this is just an
example a little trick we're saying if
this is the URL if it includes track for
the moment being returned in 999 status
code that doesn't really exist and then
here we can just do whatever we want we
can just insert anything into the
response so even though varnish here is
working as a reverse proxy it is
composing pieces from different websites
together from different services HTML
one can be cached for 30 seconds
you could put five hours in there if you
wanted to but another piece not only can
be not cashed but it can also be created
dynamically for each individual request
there are other myths around service art
composition but this is probably the
most common one that says Oh everything
has to be together what is a little bit
more tricky I'll be honest with you is
handling of the assets style sheets and
graphics and so on if you have all these
micro services and they all render
individual pieces of the HTML they all
need other resources like as I said
images and CSS this is not a simple
topic and you have to at least spend
some thought on it a standard approach
is to say for C for CSS use something to
do name spacing in the CSS so that every
team can actually work separately there
will be some duplication if on the odd
day where your company really changes
the corporate colors you will probably
have to do a synchronize release because
you have to corporate color in multiple
CSS files I don't think that's a major
problem oftentimes people say or we have
to have one sheet it can only be in one
place but really try to make the
trade-offs having it in multiple CSS
files gives you the independent
evolvability if you deploy 500 times a
week that's the more important thing
then actually having the corporate color
only in one place because that only
changes every few years normally so
there are a nice number of approaches
but I had to make a call at some point
this is a talk by a colleague of mine
that talks in detail how they did this
at one client in Europe the the QR code
is just UL as a record video recording
of a talk where they describe in greater
detail how they used mod pagespeed which
is of course a module for nginx to do
this in a different way where they use
mod pagespeed to actually get together
all the JavaScript into CSS in a
high-performance way for a high traffic
website to actually also get the
benefits of the microphone gent with the
assets
I thought about trying to pull all of
this in but then we would have been here
for two hours and not one hour so I give
you the QR code so a quick a quick
detour I want to talk a little bit more
about independent evolvability because I
haven't done that enough this is a real
example from a website that was doing
classifieds for selling used cars and
the page look roughly like this you get
the picture or multiple pictures of the
car you get a description but on the
website it's also dealers who can sell
used cars and the case was that he
wanted the contact information for the
dealer on that page let's say another
picture now imagine you are the team
that is writing the classified page
service the team that is building this
page and you want the dealer information
in there you happen to know that there's
this thing the contacts detailed service
another lovely micro service and then
you discover that they even have an HTTP
endpoint and they can give you JSON
documents and for the dealer information
you can see this here it says estilo
true and then as a street a house number
a city and a postcode this is a German
address and you can see these things
like the postcode is a number for
example you see no quotation marks
because I don't know one second
Singapore what the post costs here are
number so they see that and then the
blue team thinks oh we need to be
independent we don't have to talk to the
yellow team fantastic they've built a
service we can just call their service
and then they do that and the code flow
in one way of describing it looks
roughly like this the classified page
service calls the contact detailed
service gets this bit of JSON and then
renders it in the correct place into the
page and this is how addresses are
formatted in Germany you have the street
name the house number the zip code and
the city all well right the blue team is
happy they could implement it they
didn't have to bother the yellow team
now the rollout continues throughout
Europe for example and they go to the UK
nothing different on the classified page
but our friends in the contact detail
service they start to have UK addresses
and then there
something like this you get an address
in London you notice suddenly quotes
appear around the postcode because in UK
the postcode have numbers they didn't
even know that that was happening they
consumed that Jason and they print this
water street 76 now because they were
expecting a number which it isn't
anymore and of course if you know the UK
this is completely wrong in the UK the
house number should be before the street
name and the postcode should be behind
after the city so they thought they were
doing the right thing the blue team but
I don't think they really did because
they coupled themselves and again think
about the idea of micro front gents we
said we wanted every service to own
their own user interface here the
mistake was that didn't own the user
interface they provided data not user
interface so a better approach would
have been for the contact detailed
service trend a little bit of HTML so
they give me two paragraphs and of
course this all semantic I can format it
as much as I want the classified page
does the server-side include on edge
site include and the address appears in
the right spot what happens if the UK
gets into the fray nothing because they
know what they're doing they know how to
render yes correctly the classify page
service doesn't have to do anything
because they get the right document so
sorry the right rightly formatted
address so the idea really is he wants
to keep all that logic together in the
service that should own it they should
own not only the managing of the contact
details but the user interface so when
they own the data they can make changes
and they don't have a dependency of
course that meant for the blue team
though when they wanted to include it
they had to talk to them to say hey we
discovered your Jason interface can you
give us a user interface and maybe they
said yeah sure there is one already you
missed it all they said okay we don't
have a user interface will write one for
you all they are saying we don't have a
user interface we're super busy with
something else couldn't you do this and
maybe you just the blue team writes this
makes a pull request and they accept it
that sounds like more work up front but
in the long term you're really going
with the original
goals for each service to have to own
user interface and for them to be able
to evolve further independently okay
going back to the patterns here's a
third one client-side composition this
is sometimes helpful when you have very
very high traffic websites that needs to
have a little bit of dynamic content and
when we're doing this for a project in
the UK for a TV station and of course
when that TV program was run there was a
huge amount of traffic on the website
most of the website didn't need to
change it was just basic information
this could be pre-rendered you could use
a static site generator such as Jekyll
to actually do all the rendering and
create the fully created HTML pages but
they wanted to include a little bit
about the user
maybe the logged in user name saying
hello or you have messages or something
like that so one trick here is the
service here would render the HTML but
would also include some JavaScript and
the JavaScript could then asynchronously
when it's running here connect to
service two and retrieve some HTML and
it would know at which point to place
the HTML in the Dom tree in the web
browser so again they're completely
independent this service continuously to
deliver HTML fragments but rather than
being assembled with nginx or varnish or
another reverse proxy ultimately they're
in am they're assembled they are put
together in the web browser it's not a
pattern see you see that much anymore
but it is still a useful one to remember
what is more common these days
it's the next pattern and it's this one
here
and that's client-side rendering it's
not only composing at the client side
but it's rendering at the client side so
it looks very similar service one again
returns a lot of HTML and some
JavaScript but the JavaScript here knows
I need data from somewhere else but you
don't really want to depend too much on
the date
as we've seen can lead to big problems
so what they do is they actually
fetching some JavaScript from the other
service that javascript is then run in
here and then that javascript knows what
json data to get to actually then render
the HTML on the server-side and this is
an example actually for my own personal
website how simple something like that
can look like on that web page I mean I
was really tired when running my own
website always having to deal with
WordPress and all the security problems
and it doesn't change that often to be
honest so I also switched to a static
site generator but I wanted to show
people that I'm doing some work with
open source software and so I wanted to
show an up-to-date view of when I
committed something to get up and I
didn't want to regenerate the website
every night or so I wanted that to be
up-to-date so I used that approach and
what I'm doing here so you can see in
the top rows I'm just creating a div and
that has a name of course and it says
loading hardly anybody sees it most of
the time the Internet is fast enough and
then I'm loading a script from somewhere
and then here I'm just saying using
jQuery still does Java scrunching so
repos and this code is then going to
github is consuming the API is returning
a JSON document that Jason gets rendered
and down here it says target person
reports and the rendered HTML that was
rendered in the web browser is then
being put in that place which is why
people don't generally see the loading
but
but now the fifth and most complicated
pattern I'm going to spend a little bit
more time on this we do want or many
times these days we want to have single
page applications oftentimes there
nowadays also called pwace progressive
web applications it doesn't really
matter for what we are talking about
here whether it's either one or the
other and what the real difference is
between the two of them but the idea
really is that in these systems you
generally don't do any rendering of HTML
on the server all the rendering is
really done in the client and the
framework that I'm going to use for the
example is react jeaious but I'm sure it
will work in the same way with angular
which a lot of teams with always also
like and probably also with Buder j/s so
what's happening here like in the normal
react application or i'm any standard
react applications we're sending really
only a tiny tiny bit of HTML you know
like i don't know whether you've seen a
react application it is uses like ten
lines and it basically says i'm a
reactive application load some
javascript bootstrap code and then all
the other magic happens
all the data is actually being loaded
from the server using javascript and all
the rendering happens in the browser
so what we are conceptually doing is
it's sending a little bit of HTML the
web browser then requests JavaScript and
that JavaScript can actually pull in
some Jason to be render if we want to
compose this what we need to do is if we
want to have it from the other service
think again about the shopping cart and
the shoes it is fooling
JME javascript from the other service
and that javascript javascript was
pulled from service to is then making a
request to service to to actually get
the data it needs to render HTML what is
so important about this one it's only
one tiny box away from the big
anti-pattern this is the front end
monolith right it looks almost the same
look at the difference this is terrible
and that's fantastic
but you know why right because here I
can maintain independent evolvability if
that service changes if the data format
changes this team that is responsible
for service two can also change the
JavaScript to adapt to the different
service in the different functionality
in this case if they change the data the
JavaScript came from the other service
and they can't change it so this is the
good pattern and I want to give you a
brief explanation of how on one real
project we actually built this using
reactor JS and I need a few minutes to
do that but we have some time so at the
top you can see we are defining in the
outermost usually have something that is
sitting like a frame around that loads
the further one so if you go back here
usually you don't have service one two
you usually have like some frame the
initial application that maybe shows is
to use a lot in now maybe doesn't show
anything it's just there to load the
rest and then you don't only have one
more service usually up like three four
five different services so this is in
the Artemis frame and it's a it defines
a JavaScript object called externals you
can call it whatever you want
but this is just the things that are
being pulled in from the outside and we
do have a little bit of coupling here so
we're saying we will have this card
preview tile tile is just what we called
it in that context and it's a component
and there's a route which is part of how
react actually works and then at the
bottom we need to export this of course
for the rest of the JavaScript code to
know about it and here's one function
that I will show you in more detail what
it does but it's only being called once
the react application is initialized it
says load all the other externals and
here does it in two steps it first loads
the front-end conflict that I'll talk
about in a minute and with their front
end config it then calls load the actual
front-end so it's a two-step process it
first gets a configuration and then it
loads the additional front ends and that
is an important point
so load front and config looks like this
it fetches so let's assume this is the
blue service still it goes to an
endpoint and and says get me the config
resource there is a little JSON document
and that basically contains a mapping
from a no-name like shopping cart to
some resources usually like most of the
time just the URL where to load the
JavaScript and the CSS from could be a
little bit more of information but
that's basically the idea the and the
rest I don't know how much JavaScript
you know the rest is just boilerplate
you need to do something with
authorization and if it works you're
returning the response that jason this
is the return value here and gets into
the promise and then load front ends
will have the configuration what is
super cool about this approach is if
you're running this frame you can
configure where to load the other
services from and if you've ever worked
on a large application that has like
tens of services and you're working on a
normal laptop with 16 gigabytes of RAM
you can run into trouble I've seen in
saw works developer say they need
laptops with 32 gigabytes of memory
because it really doesn't all fit into
RAM this approach makes it quite nice
let's say you have like 10 different
services there's this framing service
and then you have like 10 different
components what you can do is you can
run the frame on your machine and you
can configure the frame to say load the
service the URL the end point for the
service I'm currently working on load
that from my machine and the other 8
services you can figure the URL to
actually point to your continuous
integration or to some other staging
environment and they will load the
JavaScript from there and the JavaScript
will also contact the service running on
there so you can run the full
application on your laptop you have only
the service that you need running on
your laptop everything else you can pull
in from somewhere else you don't have
the complexity of running all of this of
having to check out the source code
running all the front-end pipelines you
can just point at something else but you
still get the experience of having a
full website it's quite an important
benefit I would say
what you do next is and this is the
second part here you actually need to
load the front ends and you can see here
as I mentioned you get a bit of conflict
back we had here load front end contact
that gets passed in here and you can see
how in the conflict and looking up card
CSS so this is where I need to load the
style sheet from as I mentioned and this
is just a naming convention you can do
whatever you want in there and it loads
the style sheet I mean I don't think I
have to show you loading side sheets
it's very easily done in JavaScript now
the interesting part is in this conflict
dictionary that came back from the end
point here I'm getting the card
JavaScript and that is a URL and I'm
loading this and I'm passing the name to
actually put it in the right place
loading the script we tried lots of
different things
the easiest way I'm not showing the
source code for this method here for
this function but the easiest way we
found is simply to create its script tag
and put it into the Dom which will make
most modern browsers actually load the
JavaScript and then what it will do by
loading them you will have access to
this exports to a variable that I'll
show in a minute that was exported by
the JavaScript you loaded and you can
see again we're using promises here and
then we're just pushing everything that
was in the exports into the external
thing that we defined before
so now externals the object we defined
on here has a reference to all the
things that were defined in the
JavaScript for the cart and they can
make use of it and then because I don't
know how much you know about react and
redux we actually use the store here the
real App Store and we add a reducer that
we can now get from the JavaScript we
just loaded so cartridge is included the
reducer we can take it here because
we've assigned it and add it to the
store so the react application now is
extended a little bit because it knows
about the reducers in that case what I'm
not showing you in the store to actually
keep them separated you can pass prefix
you can put the state in nested objects
in the store so what we're saying
everything that the shopping cart wants
to store is actually under the prefix
cart and if you have like the article
detail page so
ABP would be under ATP and so on so
again the teams individually could work
they could store things in the react
store in the in the store in the web
browser without actually treading on
each other's toes and again could work
completely independently of course in
theory you can see some duplication here
see cart CSS cart jus cart cart and so
on and if you're loading 10 services you
might want to have another little
function where you can just pass in the
spring cart and then you have created a
convention and then you could extract
that into a method or because you're
only writing that on a two-year project
maybe once you can just copy paste those
four lines it doesn't really matter in
the end of course you're chaining up all
these promises that you're creating here
with a load script and then if you see
we're returning them here from the init
one and then whatever the react
application wants to do it loads the
JavaScript
I will admit this is slightly simplified
because you do want to handle the case
that maybe one of the server's under
certain circumstances might not be
available and then maybe you want to be
okay if the shopping cart doesn't
respond you have a problem people can't
buy anything but maybe their
recommendation engine just doesn't work
at the moment maybe you just gloss over
it and ignore it so there is sometimes a
little bit more like a couple more if
statements if you will but in
instructure it doesn't really change
very much what is important to remember
is at the top here we're seeing some
coupling and what is covered is which of
the components am i loading and that's
okay if you're writing an e-commerce
site is okay - at some point right down
yes I will have a shopping cart that's
not much of a commitment that's actually
okay you don't have to dynamically
discover that you suddenly have shopping
carts it's okay in my opinion to couple
this what is decoupled is where to load
the assets from that already is giving
you some benefits because it allows you
to split your application onto this
laptop server scenario but it's
important here is also that it is also I
mean user experience is most important
but what we have learned over the past
few years developer experience is all
super important and one thing that this
solution offers that he can do is it
allows you to do hot reloading so if you
think about how this works in the end it
just load some JavaScript but what you
can do on your laptop is because of the
way it react works if I start having
your front-end pipeline for this service
number one or the card service and as
safe the JavaScript source code the web
browser notices that and can refresh it
in the same way you would do with a
normal reactor application that is quite
different I mean an alternative approach
that on purpose I'm not showing you in
slides is another way of composition
which involves these services building
NPM packages and then the build pipeline
for something outer takes all the NPM
packages combines them but that is a bad
idea because you can't get the developer
experience right because then for each
package fee or for each component you're
changing you always have to trigger the
pipeline for the thing that combines all
the NPM packages and that means
immediately at a minimum you have a one
minute turnaround time between changing
your code and seeing in a web browser
it's not a good user experience sorry
not a good developer experience and
there Cote at the bottom there's nothing
secret somebody could write a little
JavaScript library for it I'm sure
somebody has at this stage is this very
or generic code the fact that cart
appears here is just my laziness and
trying to keep it a little bit more
concise for you so what we're seeing is
there's some coupling which i think is
ok the important thing where to load
stuff from is decoupled and how to load
something is completely generic there's
one more slide where I show you how that
is actually then being used so this is
now again the frame where you can see in
the top box how it is actually hooking
this up in the routing mechanism in
react and what we can see here is we can
now because of the setup we've done
previously we can just say externals
which is the variable that was exported
that has all the symbols and we can just
ask for the card just asked for the card
service route and we can add that
another route in react and that works
fine and then in the second box you can
see how we can actually then use the
react component again there's nothing
wrong you connect this is valid and
correct reactor j/s code I can just
say external circuit preview tile this
is now the tile that was loaded from
some completely random URL that I could
configure and it is going to be rendered
at that place what we often do is the
the service that responds to this API
config there is something that is often
configured itself through environment
variables so when we deploy it we can
actually set this is where you can find
the other things
engine where to repeat this so there is
some coupling here again I hear coupling
is bad I think it's actually okay here
again if you render the article detail
page it's actually okay to say and I do
want a shopping cart here you need to
express this somehow so I think coupling
the page that when does something to say
here carpreview child i think it's a
totally okay thing because you only do
this once very briefly this is now the
other side this is the shopping cart
that is being included and that's very
simple in components such as you just
basically say what you want to export
those JavaScript variables and then in
your front-end pipeline I forget which
one it is I think web pack one you base
you have to say I mean it's
unfortunately it's called exports here
you're basically saying what you're
trying to build your building Epcot yes
which is where all the JavaScript gets
into and that was one thing that we
fiddled with for a long time there's
different module formats and I'm not a
huge expert in JavaScript that was the
one that in the end worked and we found
this out by trial and error
so there's es6 modules and a couple of
other things the UMD format was the one
that was most easy to actually deal with
when you're loading it because that
allows you in the easiest possible way
to get access to the symbols you have
defined
I'm sure there's variations this is not
the only approach but I'm just showing
you one approach just to show you that
it's actually not that hard but that's
all you need to do and then when you're
building say the shopping cart the
front-end pipeline is running all the
time you're changing a javascript file
it builds up to GS and then the hot
loading kicks in and the application
actually sees the change in the frame in
the whole context
so these are basically it's not coupling
really I'm just defining on the side of
the included bit what it is that I'm
exporting and the key thing to remember
here is there is coupling but the
coupling is one of I add this once when
I introduced a new component whenever I
make a change to any of the components I
don't have to touch any of this not it's
not gonna work so nice you know not what
is on this page preview stage I don't
have to touch any of this none of the
teams are working on the individual
services has to go back to this bit
except you're adding a new component but
once you're working you're completely
independent and similarly you don't have
to change that and this one doesn't
change either
so this is a one-time setup in the
beginning and after that you have teams
that can work independent of each other
they can deploy without the other teams
knowing at all I mean you can have a
pipeline for example into the production
system that only builds the shopping
cart that is actually being pushed onto
a new production server a new instance
in your docker container in your cluster
whatever you want and because the web
browser from the user is making a
request to the URL it is actually
loading the latest version for you and
that is basically all I want you to say
so I'm happy to answer some more
questions
okay object I think I don't know it
depends on the use case I would say it
really depends on how flexible you
design your UI I mean this is also
simplification because this presumes
that you have a reasonably wide screen
there's probably some reactive and they
throw me a version for mobiles where
this is actually moving underneath you
don't have to use piece you can also use
spans and then leave it up to the
consumer to say whether they want to
spend underneath or they want to next to
each other it really depends but I know
what you mean about on the layout yes it
depends I think you probably have to
deal with the fact that there's a
minimum and maximum size or something
like that you at some point you have to
talk possibly yeah yeah I mean it
depends on how I mean it depends on how
much variability you have is it going
from 1 to 10 you probably have to talk
if it's two or three lines you maybe
don't have to talk it's just an example
- no rendering is done by the web
browser all right I mean the web browser
places all the elements yes it could be
it could be but I said I mean most of
the time I mean this is an example
because most of the time addresses are
written on top of each other but as I
said if you are in a use case where
you're saying I know we sometimes need
them in a long line you could probably
rather than peace use a different
element and then ask the consuming side
if you want them in lines you need to
make sure that they are positioned
correctly
it depends on the use case this is just
one example in some examples you can do
it like that in others you can do it
differently sometimes you also get I
mean they might give you a long version
or it may not for an address but for
other things you could have a long or
short version and then you can pick
which one you want that make sense okay
I'm slowly making my way would have
stood in front of the laptop and press
the right button so the question is what
do you need to do if you need to share
information between the services or
especially in the web interface I guess
this question always gets asked I
probably should add a slide to the
presentation you have again a number of
different patterns so one very robust
pattern is to not do it I mean you can
always use something like WebSockets or
so I mean for example if you think about
the shopping cart this might not
actually be the worst idea you can also
be in a situation where you have a call
center and you're on the phone and the
call center agent is saying I'm taking
and putting something to your shopping
basket not a pair of shoes but if you're
booking flights or so this could happen
so maybe the application that is running
in the web browser needs we prepare that
the state is changing on the server
anyway and be able to listen for an
event so what could happen then is that
service one is sending a request to its
service on the backhand side and that
service has some asynchronous or
otherwise communication with the other
service and that then pushes the change
back to the user interface so the two
bits of JavaScript don't talk to each
other at all and I remember a case where
we did exactly that because the
application was built in such a way that
service 1 was developed by one company
and service 2 was developed by the other
company and the synchronization overhead
and for reliability reasons was just too
complicated so he said we would only do
asynchronous communication on the server
side but of course as I said the
JavaScript needed to be capable of
receiving through a WebSocket a change
on the server side and then it worked
there's two other ways especially when
you use react one is you can actually
use these
store object that you have you can
actually have a shared area there that's
nothing it's just a convention again you
can put another you can put a shared
object in and then but that becomes a
contract between the two pieces of
JavaScript that they know there's
something in the shared area we have
done this in one application
where ya the two javascript pieces
needed to know a selected entity
something that was selected and then we
try to have a minimum contract so the
only thing that was in shared was the ID
of the entity that was shared and if
that changed
the service could then load its
information about the ID from its own
back-end service so let's say the blue
service pushes a change and says the ID
is now changed and then the yellow
service would see it and would say oh
for this ID to get me my information and
that brings which was a third way also
in react what is very easy to do because
you're sending these actions around
oftentimes you don't notice it but the
actions video only strings most of the
time when you write idiomatic react code
you're using a variable name that's how
it's defined because you don't want to
miss type it and so on but in fact it is
only a string so what you can do is you
can use that as an avenging mechanism
inside the web browser so what you can
do is the the service one that is
running here could say I have now
changed something and then again it
becomes a contract what the name of the
action is but another service can
register for that action and can do
something based on that action it is
very tempting to always do that because
it feels nice the problem though is
you're often getting back into this
event hell that we try to get out of
with react because of I mean one way
binding made a lot of things much more
sane but if you now have one service
sending an event that service two
listens to and then service two there's
something and creates an event and then
service three and four listen to it you
can quickly get back to a lot of the
events but these are basically ways of
dealing with communication between the
two of them men with varying degrees of
coupling the important thing though is
the moment you use either that store
approach or you use the event those to
become contracts and I got asked the
question once do you do contract testing
on those ideally you probably should but
when I have seen this we didn't do it
because it was actually quite
complicated to do
if you want to a while I can't
understand you very well so you're
saying if you want to avoid this our
WebSockets the only option yeah yeah
WebSockets because that means the server
can initiate of course some transfers or
some we display in the web browser I
mean of course instead of WebSockets you
can always use polling but that's hugely
a bad idea for yes it would oh sorry
without yeah if you use WebSockets it
scales better if you don't use
WebSockets of course it doesn't scale as
well because you need to do polling yeah
I think it's not too bad I mean with
HTTP 1 you can always use keepalive so
it's using one HTTP connection shouldn't
make much of a difference really
yes but gee Jen we want that anyway
because you you don't want to use I mean
if you use an authentication solution
you don't want to have you don't want to
use it to login into multiple different
components right you generally want to
have in any case I need to needed to
make the diagram it's a little bit more
abstract but in any case you generally
have some reverse proxy in front that
does the distribution to the different
back-end services and you don't have to
I mean the example for my personal
website and github shows you don't have
to but most of the time you actually
have that situation that there's a
reverse proxy in between and as I said
with keepalive is usually not such a big
deal and to be honest the biggest thing
is normally either the libraries or
nowadays in the times of Retina displays
actually the graphical assets and not so
much the minified javascript that you've
written yourself
good point yes web components I didn't
mention them right and I also didn't
mention one thing I was wondering
whether you noticed that in that
approach
you have to use the same version of
react basically because the the frame is
loading the react library and then it is
loading all the individual JavaScript I
think from a user experience perspective
that is the better approach web
components in theory there in the end
that they have been around for a very
long time web components in theory would
allow you even more independence each of
the components could have their own
framework honesty I have not seen this
in the wild I have not seen anybody use
web components for that I thought works
are very curious about it and we're in a
lucky position there in some countries
including Germany we are normally based
we work with universities and we
currently have one student writing a
thesis about the idea of using web
components for microphone teams so that
student is really trying to figure out
how that would work and whether web
components could indeed be a good
solution for it as I said I've not seen
it in the wild but a briefly wanted to
come back to the idea of using web
components and the freedom it gives you
it would in theory give you the freedom
to write say this piece in JavaScript in
one version of react and that piece in a
different version of react giving you
more independent evolved ability and
that is important for the organization
that is writing the software but I think
everything is less important than the
experience for the user and if you have
eight services and they're running in
web components and they each have the
Liberty to use a different version of
react then you would load react eight
times and that is probably not a
fantastic idea
it's independent yeah I understand
yes what yes but for
yes I totally agree with you web
components have a lot of promise and
they would solve some of those issues at
the moment we often use workarounds
right for the CSS I forget what it's
called there's this module that mangles
the names
I think it's called CSS modules right
yeah and then a BEM is also another one
which is more like a convention of how
to name your CSS so it doesn't collide
with you these are workarounds and yes
it gives you web components would give
you better isolation as I'm saying I'm
super excited about this thesis to see
what are the benefits but it is also for
me an observation I mean I work with as
a consultant we work with multiple
companies not seen anybody do this with
web components and I've always been
passing myself because I understand the
benefits but I I want to see what stops
people from doing it or maybe it's just
because nobody has done it but yeah but
I mean it has been in its infancy for
like what four years five years I mean
it should be supported and now with even
Microsoft switching to to the new
rendering engine to chromium there's
only like Firefox and chromium left or
Safari is a slight variation I think it
should be possible to do it we'll see
maybe if we talk in two years you would
do it but I briefly find I briefly
wanted to come back to this idea of
loading multiple versions of react
because just because you could it's a
bad idea
what we think what I think we can do is
we can learn in that case a little bit
from the the lot of work that companies
that Google and Facebook have done
around mono repos I mean they are doing
a lot of this on the server side I'm
unconvinced
I've spoken to some people have even
spoken to one of my old colleagues who
ended up being at Facebook to write back
which is a special build tool to allow
mono repos so I'm unconvinced on the
server side but I think on in the on the
web browser it can actually probably
make sense to learn some of that when
you have to deal with it and then of
course what it's also important to
remember is there's a lot of security
problems in the front end side in the
user interface and if you use that
approach and the first team that wants
to switch to a new reactor application
has to make sure the other teams were
with that can potentially be actually a
good thing for your security
so sabotage yes the server-side ones are
really good when you have really high
traffic and you want search engine
optimization when you don't want to
render something different I mean there
are a ton of other approaches too but
generally when you have a big ecommerce
website I'm using e-commerce as an
example here it works so many other
things too you have a product catalog
and you want the search engines to
actually provide deep links it's of
course easier if you render HTML and I
don't know what happened to it I think
Google wants to have a minimum
JavaScript implementation to actually be
able to render your pages for search I'm
not sure what came of that there are all
sorts of other ways there are
technologies was it called again there's
one technology that actually allows you
to have client-side we're not but it
basically uses a browser
part on the server side to render the
HTML on the server if the search engine
comes your way so it's actually quite
good for for the tech and of course it
actually creates minimum load it is easy
to cache the browser's are are simple to
use these ones are harder to program
because you have to use more JavaScript
you have to do more testing in the
browser and it gives you of course on
the other hand more interactivity yeah
this is interactivity right I mean
especially the applications we sometimes
see that companies are writing for
internal use oftentimes they're
replacing applications that were written
with Windows forms or whatever the
JavaScript the Java one was called SFX
no I can't remember whatever these
applications were they're now being
replaced and we're doing this we are
building the application that all their
dealers that mercedes-benz they are
selling mercedes-benz cars both in China
as well as in Germany this is a react
application and that's very interactive
right I mean you can there's all sorts
of like these take tile like things and
you can configure the car and so on you
could never do that
the static webpage right I mean just to
scroll up and down and choose all the
different trimmings and so on that
really feels like an application for
many reasons they did not want to write
native applications for mobile devices
it needs to work on a PC for the sales
representatives as well as an iPad in
the showroom so a web application is the
best way and that is often where we see
the push I mean we've done this also for
all sorts of applications I mean we did
another one for logistics part of a big
yeah for a big company and the drivers
when they drive around they get all the
route planning and so on it's a react
application you couldn't do that with
HTML really and at the same time they
still combine multiple things and then
you can use an approach like this oh
it's quick I'm gonna start from the
right so you say
I'm not familiar enough with angular to
really comment on it the one thing I
would wonder is if you change the
component can you hot reload that in the
browser or do you have to build the NPM
package again
I'm not a hunson wave yes that was what
I meant with develop experience that you
don't want to have to rebuild anything
that when you're working on the
components I'm sure I mean I've seen
component libraries as well if it's
small things like buttons and so on that
can make a lot of sense you can also
share the holes in a story book or so
but yeah I'll know I said I'm not a big
angular expert so I don't know the most
again it depends on what what you yeah
then the most common way of doing this
today that I'm seeing is that use some
form of an SSO
so no matter where you go it will check
whether there's a cookie and if you
don't have a cookie normally a JWT token
if you don't have it it'll bounce it to
an SSO server there you log in that
bounces you back that takes apart the
whole thing issues a JWT token and then
the user can continue now that begs the
question of course if I go to say the
article detail page here this needs to
understand the JWT token but then I go
somewhere else to the page in this
example here the shopping page that also
needs to understand a JWT token and
suddenly you find yourself that each and
every service has to understand the JWT
token format and you can't take that
lightly
you can't just decrypt it you also need
to check the signature because otherwise
of course anybody on the internet could
say I'm an admin here's my token so then
you find yourself having the need in
both of these services and potentially
all of the services to add the code for
analyzing the JWT tokens which we really
really don't want to do in my opinion a
bad approach but better than nothing is
to create a shared library but shared
libraries are usually fraught with
problems because then you write them in
Java and some
using even just like cotton although
it's on the JVM but maybe they write it
in a different programming language and
then the library doesn't work or
somebody forgets to update it and so on
and so on so it's not a great idea
shared libraries are generally I would
say discouraged you shouldn't do that
one option that I've seen being used
quite a lot is to integrate that into
the reverse proxy which you inevitably
have and for example in nginx one thing
that I worked on recently we wrote a lot
of the backend stuff in closure anyway
and nginx can be extended with closure
and we wrote a little bit of code in
nginx that takes apart the JWT token
makes all the necessary checks and then
adds that as HTTP headers onto the
downstream services so the request comes
in and X takes apart the JWT token
verifies the signature and then puts
username and some entitlements and so on
as normal HTTP headers and the services
behind here they can believe it now
because they know somebody else check
the JWT talking further down and of
course the most I know the most
fashionable and hip way is of course to
use service mesh when you are using a
service mesh then it becomes very easy
because you have a sidecar and you can
put all of these things in a sidecar you
know the idea right I mean you have in
common agency of the pods and you have
the your service is running next to
something else that is delivered by the
service mesh and then the service which
can deal with it you are in it is yeah
where does the layering start is it su
platform I know it is I mean in many
ways so it is separation of concerns
that gives you more flexibility I mean
separation of concerns you already get
with the nginx because then the concern
of actually verifying the authenticity
of the JWT token is separated from the
services yes there's many different SSA
there's many different ways but these
are the most common ones shared library
not a great fan reverse proxy or then
sidecars for authentication
that's what I mean you can have a chat
library that does this and that is
linked or embedded into all the services
or because even in that example in all
these examples maybe it can only get so
much onto a diagram it is always going
normally through a reverse proxy and you
can put it into the reverse proxy before
it actually ever hits the service and
then the service doesn't it can be sweet
an HTTP header and the header is called
user ID and whatever is in there the
service can believe because it knows
that somebody else has checked this
beforehand
maybe I should say that that is not an
approach and this may be coming back to
the angular question also this is not an
approach to do components like a
drop-down list or a date picker or
button there's an approach for micro
services
micro services these services should be
business relevant components I mean if
you look at the definition or definition
the description that Martin and James
wrote about micro services they wrote
down like eight different
characteristics and one was am i per
service should really represent a
business capability a date picker or
drop-down is not a business capability
so this is really more for integrating
chunkier bits
you'll be loading your that you'll be
loading JavaScript code that you have
developed your teams have developed
that's what this is about
exactly what I'm saying most of the time
when you do this you do want have a
reverse proxy in front and they're
running on the same domain so they all
get the JWT token right yes it can get
it from the web browser it is running in
this on the same in the same context
right I'm not sure I understand the
question yeah yeah I mean that cookie I
know what you mean I meant about that
cookie is accessible to the JavaScript
code right it's going to be sent anyway
I mean if you if you take the example
that I gave with say this one here and
that's running on a different domain you
have a problem then you would probably
behind the scenes see this dance once
but as long as you do something like
this or in such an example you would
generally have a reverse proxy here then
they all go into the same domain and
whether you get some HTML or some
JavaScript or some some JSON document
you can always include the JWT token or
it is always included it is taken apart
by the reverse proxy and the services
then have the information they need
yeah that's
there's no good answer first it really
depends I mean sometimes you need a
back-end for front-end depending on
bandwidth requirements depending on how
many different devices you have with
very different use cases if you are
SoundCloud or Netflix or somebody like
this that is in like smartwatches and
speakers all the way to TVs and PCs you
might need a back-end for front-end
sometimes you don't I don't know ah good
that you asked yeah yes yeah I know so
native mobile applications and because
if you will ladies mobile applications
are also a front-end monolith right and
here it's really tough to say
I mean I've not seen very many people
try this there is made available open
source software by one of the big
Chinese companies I think it's Alibaba
but I'm not a ton of sense sure there is
a set of oh it is for iOS and Android
open source software that allows you to
modularize in iOS a mobile application I
think one was called beehive but I'm not
I'm same sure it's a bit like OSGi on
the Java side so you can load things I
don't know the problem I think here's
again the user experience but also the
developer experience the native
applications always get installment with
some exceptions in the enterprise space
I understand that but they generally get
deployed through an app store and you
don't have the same deployment frequency
for mobile applications anyway you're
not doing 500 releases per week you have
to find a different way to make it
manageable you can automate most of the
App Store processes but at some point
even if you could and you could deploy
once every couple of hours you don't
want to do it because your users will
completely hate you for it right
so I mean I don't like them at all I
mean we've actually in on the Saltworks
technology radar in the current edition
we've specifically put release trains as
a technique to avoid in general but I
think for mobile applications there is
probably the right way to actually come
up with some release train and then do
it once a week and at that point you
probably don't need that anymore you you
can assemble it on the Southside it's
not ideal I know and some of the
benefits I talked about from a
deployment perspective sorry from a
development perspective you don't get
but they are really not made for this I
think the frameworks I don't know
anything about Android development I
know a bit about iOS development at
least there you can have separate pieces
like the storyboards and accept files
you can make them separate but then you
still need one bill to put them together
but as I said in the end you cannot
can't really deploy in the same way as
you can do on the web I'm not sure what
will happen I mean Google really try to
push hard and progressive web
applications I mean I used an iPhone so
I know that Apple really doesn't like
them very much I don't know how many of
you know this but I think Starbucks is
an example of an application that can
actually pin to the home screen but
Apple really doesn't make it easy there
is a way you can I think on the website
if you go to share and then like further
down in the gray section you can say pin
to home screen or so they really don't
want you to do it but of course for many
organizations that want to deploy
rapidly and want to have these cycles it
would be much much easier to use web
technology but yeah with the with the
applications as long as they go through
the App Store it's really tough if
that's your problem if you have a big
application I mean I also know like some
of the larger organizations they talk a
lot about application portfolios and
there's always this thing should they
have one massive application like if you
think about WeChat that does everything
from chatting to payment to something
else or like I mean if you take a
typical airline you have one application
to like to check in and book flights
another one to check your mileage
account and a third one for the
in-flight entertainment do you have
multiple applications and then your
split even more but if you really want
to put everything in one I guess there
are the open source for immersive it
explore but I have not seen them used in
yeah navigation to me is a component
like this if there should be a service
and that's what I've seen especially
here on that approach on websites that
the navigation is one top-level thing
that is included and there's one
specific service that is respon exactly
yeah
and would decide which goes where maybe
even for different customer segments you
can run a be test but by swapping around
things by checking different ways the
navigation service
yeah the idea is that they try to use
the same versions merriment I mean we
have to learn really from what people
did with mono rappers on the server side
and find a way for them to share the
same version it's really difficult to
get this to work without web components
for them to have different versions and
I totally get that it limits the
independent evolvability because you now
have to call in it you have to die one
death as they say because I mean the
other thing I mean if everybody I mean
if you look at the current JavaScript
applications you often have so many
libraries you don't really want if you
have and it's not uncommon you have like
10 different services if they all use
their own version of react and the own
version of redux one of them uses
immutable J's the other one uses images
and it's just adding and adding and
adding and then you're suddenly loading
I don't know 10 20 megabytes of just
JavaScript code which is really bad
impression on first load for the users
that first come to your website because
then even if you strong caching they
don't really have it cache their
download the whole thing doesn't look
very good so I know it's not a great
answer as I said I mean the best
approach that I've seen so far is to try
to to arrange between the teams but then
yeah of course if a new version of react
comes out if one switch do you have a
coordination problem yes as I said the
hierarchy is the user first and then the
developer and then the architect
I know okay so if there are more
questions I would like to thank you
thanks for coming fantastic questions
[Applause]